das ist nicht übertrieben es ist ein
historischer tag denn seit heute haben
wir endlich den offiziellen
untersuchungsausschuss zur pkw maut
jetzt wird es bitter für an die scheuer
mit den nerven am limit fix und fertig
im grunde nur noch haut und knochen und
herren sind zum glück gab es heute im
bundestag auch zumindest ein paar
aufmunternde worte für den an die von
parteifreunden dobrindt zum beispiel und
an etwas macht es ab nächste woche
beruflich ja weiß nicht ist halt
schwierig ohne schulabschluss kennst du
ja auch ein alter noch die oberin du
hast mir den spaß dennoch vererbt
dennoch war sein
hallo ich bin die ich habe den mord
verkackt es ist kein einfacher tag für
ihn keine frage natürlich hat sich
scheuer die maut nicht alleine
ausgedacht
trotzdem ist er für mich schon so was
wie der lord voldemort der deutschen
politik ja ja entschuldigung weil er
eben auch kein schuldbewusstsein zeigt
500 millionen kostet uns der maut
quatsch ich sag mal so in deutschland
sind schon politiker wegen weit weniger
zurückgetreten
jetzt mal ehrlich warum tritt ja nicht
zurück ich habe sehr viel freude an dem
amt weil ich auch sehr viele pläne für
deutschland habe da
das hat unser land nicht verdient meine
damen und herren selbst die
mautbetreiber hatten ihm wohl gewarnt
ausdrücklich gewarnt lasst uns doch mit
dem vertrag warten bis zum ogh urteil
aber er musste ja unbedingt zocken mit
meinem geld das schön schön alles auf
die maut gesetzt also auf ein halb
blindes rennpferd mit gipsbein vielen
dank ich hoffe dem an die geht jetzt
ordentlich die muffe vor diesem
untersuchungsausschuss
du hast seehofer hat mir am mittwoch
früh gesagt dass er sechs
untersuchungsausschüsse hatte ja nämlich
mitunter fünf ausschüssen wirst in der
csu nicht mal gegrüßt
da bist du quasi noch jungfrau die
mautbetreiber haben den komplett über
den tisch gezogen und jetzt muss der
steuerzahler den für volle 12
vertragsjahren die kohle hätten
reinschieben komplett mehrmals hat sich
scheuer heimlich mit denen getroffen
ohne jedes gesprächsprotokoll dabei
hatte doch wirklich monate lang
behauptet wir stehen bei allen fragen
zur pkw maut für maximal mögliche
transparenz
wir möchten eine maximal mögliche
transparenz herstellen
ich stelle machen sie mal mögliche
transparenz her wenn wir maximal
mögliche transparenz und das ist mein
politikstil hergestellt haben diese
transparenz wollten wir als bmw von
anfang an des tages ja offenbar hat
unser maximal unfähiger verkehrsminister
sogar die wahren mautkosten verschleiert
der bundestag hatte ihm nur zwei
milliarden für den unsinn genehmigt es
hätte aber drei gekostet wie konnte man
denn ohne not diesen vertrag vorzeitig
unterschreiben und gibt es dagegen nicht
irgendwas von ratiopharm ein problem
würde es mir nicht gerne reden
vor lauter erregung unterschreiben sie
ihren mietvertrag viel zu früh die folge
schmerzhafte untersuchungsausschüsse und
peinliche interviews aber gegen ein
vorzeitiges unterschreiben gibt es jetzt
was signatur worte das antibiotikum für
verkehrsminister in den kritischen
jahren
denn wenn deine duve unterschrift unter
eine halbe million gekostet das ist ja
nun wirklich der gipfel des tages genau
signatur forte gegen vorzeitigen tinten
ergoss
der anlieger
ja wenn man alles zusammenzählt
insgesamt eine echt harte woche für die
csu denn auch der parteitag vom letzten
wochenende lief ja suboptimal wir
erinnern uns markus söder wollte ja
seine partei die csu moderner machen
jünger und weiblicher so jetzt jetzt hat
sich aber herausgestellt die csu diese
renitente undankbare brut will das gar
nicht mit seinem versuch auch für
kreisvorstände eine verpflichtende 40
prozent frauenquote einzuführen ist
söder wirklich krachend gescheitert
dabei ist der östrogenmangel in der csu
ja gar nicht zu streiten
da kannst du dir irgend eine szene vom
parteitag angucken wir kommen jetzt zum
handlungsfeld vier jünger weiblicher
zukunftsweg die csu als moderne
volkspartei in diesem bild hat unser
zeichner drei fehler versteckt damen und
herren
jetzt sieht so aus wie viele frauen am
ende in einem csu kreisvorstand sitzen
entscheidet weiter der kreisvorstand
selbst also kurz gesagt die männer so
dass quoten idee ich sage von anfang an
ein absolutes himmelfahrtskommando
wirklich ja man muss es so sagen
und mal ganz ehrlich es war ist eine
ehrliche frage warum müssen denn jetzt
alle parteien modernen werden warum wo
sollen dann die ganzen unmodernen leute
hin quote auf mich ständig mit dem
rechenschieber als kreisvorsitzender
dann letztendlich ausrechnen müssen wie
wir die quoten erfüllen die wir uns auch
verleger es ist ein absoluter albtraum
ich bitte sie für soll ich denn mit dem
rechenschieber
mal angenommen immer im vorstand sind
zehn männer und eine frau wie viel
frauen brauche ich da jetzt
man konnte es durchaus rechnen ist
glücklich
made in china
also zur klarstellung natürlich mag
keiner quoten wäre besser wenn wir die
nicht bräuchte aber bei nur 21
weiblichen mitgliedern läuft hier wohl
irgendwas schief mein eindruck ist viele
csu männer verstehen das ganze prinzip
nicht was ist denn wenn wir 100 prozent
frauen haben dann sind die männer nicht
berücksichtigt wenn wir also eine quote
brauchen dann doch bitte auch eine
männerquote nein kommt soviel zum tollen
bayerischen schulsystem ja es gibt doch
nicht so wenig frauen in der politik
weil sie schlechter werden sondern bei
männer skrupelloser netzwerken immerhin
teile der csu haben begriffen es muss
was passieren wir schauen mal live in
die bayerische staatskanzlei nach
münchen
dort leitet ulrich von heesen die
taskforce jünger und weiblicher und wie
man sieht es besteht handlungsbedarf
pawelke das ist die große frage wie
lockt man frauen in die csu ab sofort
kriegt jede die neueintritt dieses
begrüßungspaket mit nach vanille
duftkerze dann natürlich bade perlen mit
markus söder aroma und eine ganze
packung sommer ist die offen meint
manfred es ist halt alles komplizierter
geworden früher wenn ein dorf in
niederbayern zu wenig frauen hatte dann
ist man ins nachbardorf und hat sich
geholt das ist wohl heute sagen unsere
anwälte grauzone
also was tun ja quote zum beispiel quote
ist scheiße in der csu entscheiden nicht
geschlechtsteile über den erfolg sondern
qualifikationen die besten müssen sich
durchsetzen
nehmen sie nur mal unsere letzten drei
verkehrsminister ramsauer dobrindt der
an die scheuer die geistige elite der
partei
welche frau frage ich sie könnten da
mithalten
quasi jede also mit anderen worten
einfach weiter so eben nicht die csu hat
doch was gehen jahres beschlossen
parteitage und vorstandssitzungen sind
kein witz ab sofort auch virtuell
beschlussfähig ideal gerade für frauen
die können dann an sitzungen teilnehmen
und trotzdem ihre hausarbeit erledigen
hallo monika ja hallo ich habe ganz
soweit leichten ganz konkreten vorschlag
und zwar zum thema ganztagsbetreuung
wäre es denn wenn wir endlich ich habe
jetzt noch mal auf stumm gestellt
du kriegst sonst auch kopfschmerzen von
der hohen stimme aber klar es muss was
passieren
keine frage diese partei hat ein problem
79 prozent männer 21 prozent frauen
überspitzt gesagt die csu ist ein
älterer mann und wird jetzt eine jüngere
frau wäre das ist die lösung ältere
männer müssen junge frauen werden
ja und wie geht das ganz einfach jeder
zieht ein streichholz tut mir leid
manfred los jungs halten ihn fest
glücklich zumal das gibt jetzt ein
bisschen aber ist doch besser als quote
wahrscheinlich ulrich von heesen
mein arzt hat mir verboten mich
weiterhin so aufzuregen
deswegen wollte ich euch allen einfach
nur einen schönen tag wünschen überall
lassen ihre techniken liegen und ihr
lasst jetzt das xenix ein beschissenes
ab
[Musik]